should a filmmaker think about where
they're going to sell their film
before they make it absolutely
absolutely
i mean there's the there's the plan and
there's the wishful thinking
so the plan is if all else fails
let's start with the bottom the lowest
common denominator i mean
we'll start with the top it's easier
okay the top would be
go to a festival get accepted into a big
festival get your movie seen by a big
movie company
they make you an offer they take it off
your hands give you a big amount of
money
and life is really good do not depend on
that
i'm not saying it can't happen it likely
won't happen all right
um and they you know they'll sell it to
all the right players and you're done
all right
so let's say that doesn't happen i hope
it does happen for all you indie
filmmakers but if it doesn't which it
likely won't
plan number two get it into a lower
level festival
now that's more of a celebration because
buyers don't really attend those
festivals but you can get some audience
feedback and get some buzz maybe some
critical
you know maybe some you know awards
something like that that will help you
to get the attention then you got to get
into the distribution cycle
so the distribution cycle is either
finding a distributor
or sales agent um do you want me to
explain the difference between a sales
agent and a distributor
sure okay so a sales agent i mean again
they're melding into sort of one and the
same these days
but a sales agent generally finds you a
distributor
a distributor generally finds places
your
your film in the homes of where people
are going to view it like ie the
streaming services the broadcasters
whatever
a distributor is we call them destroy
because they get the movie out they
distribute the movie out to
the places where it will get consumed
which is primarily
television now streaming and video on
demand all right and you know
airlines and all that kind of stuff
whereas a sales agent
doesn't deal necessarily with
broadcasters and streamers
they deal with distributors so sometimes
it's hard to get to distributors because
especially before the fact before you
make your movie they want to deal only
with finished films
and they don't have a lot of time and
they want to deal with bigger budget
films so it's it's often
very very tricky to navigate that and
they're they're a bit of a pain in the
butt to be honest with you
and they're not responsive and they're
um and some of them aren't even credible
so it's usually easier to get through a
sales agent who can represent you into
a distributor the problem with that is
you're going to pay two levels of
commissions
you're gonna pay the sales agent their
commission which is somewhere between 10
and 15 percent
generally and then a distributor is
going to take somewhere between 20 and
30 percent
now some will ask for 35 or 40 but
you know in a second i'm going to talk
about what not to accept in a
distribution deal
so so you're adding an extra level of
distribution
and an extra you know level of
transmission of funds
and everything starts to get diluted but
if you don't have any other
way to get there then you know that you
have to do that
but let's say that fails too let's say
you can't get a distributor let's say
you can't get a sales agent to get you a
distributor for whatever reason nobody's
available you've asked everybody and
they're just not responsive
that leaves you to self-distribute now i
personally believe in self-distribution
because i have a lot of distribution
experience
and i a bit of a control freak i like to
do it my way
and you know i respect the fact that
people are doing jobs but if
i don't like to pay commissions for when
people don't do their job properly
so self-distribution is tricky it's hard
to navigate
but it's not any trickier than making a
movie i mean you just finished making a
movie
you spent your life doing that and your
resources and you navigated all that
so you just got to get creative you got
to switch gears and you have to say okay
now i'm going to get creative in
marketing
and i'm going to try to get out to an
audience the problem is is that most
creative artistic people feel that
that's a business function and they
don't do that
that's one is they don't like to do it
two is they don't know how to do it
three is they don't want to do it so
that means you're kind of stuck where do
you go what do you do
i mean you you don't have a home for
your movie and then you get aggravated
and frustrated which is
you know a lot of indie stories you hear
about that right
so you wait and you wait and wait and
hope that
i mean you hope that something happens
but it usually doesn't
so you kind the good news about the
digital era right now is that
it's not that hard to self-distribute
i'm not saying it's going to be
that successful but like for instance
putting your movie up on amazon
and i'm not talking amazon prime the
streaming side of it i'm talking about
prime video you know the transactional
side
is real easy i mean you send it in you
fill it in a submission thing
they review it it's not that hard to do
you know i have to make delivery you
have to make sure you can deliver the
elements they need and
and the trailer and the artwork and that
kind of stuff but
you just made a movie you should be able
to do that you should be capable of
doing that i know you're not going to
like it i know an indie filmmaker is not
going to love doing it
so and if you don't then find somebody
who does find a friend find a marketing
person find somebody who
will take that on and help out and would
you need eno insurance
before you do that or is that a
requirement of being on some of those
platforms yeah you know is primarily
i mean you have to have you know if
you're on any television and
any streamer because they they want to
be you know
they want to be covered with that
liability so you know there's errors in
emissions by the way for people who
don't know
and that is if you did something that
you weren't supposed to do like you
showed
a you depicted a character a name of
person or some building or something
like that you weren't licensed to do
that
you could get sued and the television
station doesn't want to
carry that liability of being sued for
that so that's what that insurance
covers
generally speaking these the
transactional
video on demand or don't ask for you
know that's not one of the criteria but
you know it's a really good question to
be honest with you i've never not had
you know
everything i just automatically get you
know because i sell to streaming
companies
but i'm going to need to look into that
whether or not you need eno for
transactional
video on demand i don't know
with eno insurance are there different
levels different packages
yeah yeah um it goes by it's like any
type of insurance it goes by how much
coverage you want
so um you know usually the minimum it
used to be a million dollars these days
and it's
now i believe it up to about 3 million
for major broadcasters
so they want their liability level to be
at three million per incident
and then 10 million cumulatively if
there are multiple incidents
those are standard packages um that's
for indie films
that's the coverage right that's not the
policy the policy
can go anywhere depending on it's
negotiable right this is like buying any
insurance
it's like buying health insurance or
home insurance or in like that you know
it's a range
but within the range there's a couple of
bells and whistles like what's your
deductible
deductible going to be i mean there's a
deductible right so
it's no different than buying any other
insurance but
generally speaking a broadcast will want
it at a certain range which is about 3
million
minimum unless it's a big big big show
and might be five million
something like that and how long would
one need the policy to be in effect
great question so um
generally if there's going to be an
error or a mission or something like
that it will be seen within the first
two years
it will generally be seen within the
first two years of it going on to some
type of broadcasting thing
so generally these policies are two to
three years um some people take them for
five
sometimes even ten years just because
they're selling over and over to
different people and
and other people request it but also in
the case of an indie film
you're generally going to get like one
selling cycle like it's going to go out
there is going to get sold
and you don't really have to buy
coverage
for what will be down the line if you're
lucky enough and there's like it comes
say you sell to
netflix and it's a three-year four-year
deal right and it comes off in netflix
don't buy another four years up front
until netflix renews if netflix or news
and they say hey you need more you know
then go and buy that
you know for the for the second period
there's no point in
spending the money now even though it's
cheaper obviously to buy it
longer term but you may not need it for
a second term
you